sprechen wir jetzt über kriminalität in
zeiten von corona mit dem mannheimer
chef der gewerkschaft der polizei thomas
[ __ ] hemmoor ganz herzlich willkommen
hier bei bild sie waren in den letzten
wochen auch auf streife mussten selber
miterleben während ihrer arbeit wie es
zu corona auseinandersetzung kam
wie hat corona das gewaltpotenzial der
menschen verändert hier im land und wir
stellen hier fest dass es nach den
lockerungen wenn die leute jetzt wieder
auf die straße dürfen
das ist wieder zu streitigkeiten kommt
in supermärkten dass die leute teilweise
unseren einsatzkräften probleme machen
wenn sie gegen die verordnung gegen die
abstandsregeln verstoßen und sie werden
dann beanstandet dass die leute sehr
uneinsichtig sind und auch das
aggressionspotenzial hat zugenommen
sie sprachen gerade von diesen
auseinandersetzungen wir haben ja auch
bilder gesehen auseinandersetzungen bei
denen es genau worum gehts ja es geht
eigentlich um banale dinge
das hätte man vorher gar nicht geglaubt
dass leute wegen geringfügigen dingen in
streit geraten und persönlich erkläre
ich mir das so
die waren natürlich auch jetzt über
wochen zu hause und da hat sich
vielleicht auch etwas aggression an
gestand aber wir haben jetzt hier die
erfahrung gemacht dass unsere streifen
zu situationen gerufen werden die
eigentlich sehr banal sind aber die dann
in der am ende eskalieren und auch
teilweise einsatzkräfte angegriffen
werden und sie mussten am wochenende
auch bekanntschaft mit einer gruppe
jugendlicher machen die sich nicht so
richtig halten wollte an die korona
maßnahmen kann sie uns davon berichten
ja es war jetzt aktuell am wochenende da
haben sich circa 100 bis 150 jugendliche
und heran
wachsende in mannheim versammelt am
langen kopf das ist der schnittpunkt
fußgängerzonen und zum wasserturm
dort hat man sich versammelt hat
natürlich gegen das abstandsgebot
verstoßen und als dann unsere corona
streiten die personalien erheben wollten
kam es dann zum eklat die gruppe hat
sich solidarisiert und wir mussten 20
streifenwagen besatzungen schicken um
die lage in den griff zu kriegen